moi je me rappelle on m'avait dit tu vas
rencontrer jean michel mr sa tension
c'est un intello jamais vraiment vous
avez été recruté en moi en fait celle où
l'histoire quand en fait c'est 8
m'appelez pas des huit à l'époque mon
appel pour faire nouvelle star ils me
disent il faudra faire touche pas à mon
poste et par orgueil je voulais dire
expliqué j'ai dit ça jamais jamais donc
j'ai perdu du temps parce que j'ai fait
donc une nouvelle star et j'étais très
bien lancé chaque semaine par thierry
s'était jamais avec un gars est en fait
j'ai perdu du temps et c'est vrai qu'on
était on était potes sans plus avec
cyril j'ai été faire un tour nrj 12 est
trop petit tour et puis je donc
retrouver sans rien et sérieux m'a
rappelé et c'est en ça que c'est plutôt
agréable qui m'a rappelé mon et voilà
j'ai un jeu que camil devait faire
kim a tout dit ma di leva et et ont
rejoint nous fait touche pas à mon poste
et voilà je suis très heureux parce
qu'en plus d'avoir gagné une émission
j'ai gagné un ami voilà
[Applaudissements]
être avec nous avant tu es prêt jean
michel maire vous comment vous avez été
recruté à bas c'est un coup du destin
incroyable j'étais aux filières à
l'époque j'étais chroniqueur sur une
chaîne qui n'existe plus l'appeler de
tps star
il ya beaucoup de chine quand vous
passez derrière voilà c'était une
émission média un peu sérieuse qui se
voulait sérieuse et il se trouve que
j'avais démissionné du figaro et donc du
coup je démissionnais aussi l'émission
puisque c'est un club de la presse
n'avait plus rien à y faire et il trouve
que coup du sort le dernier invité de
cette émission là c'est vous incroyable
et du coup l'émission se termine je
remet alors on m'avait invité parce
qu'en fait je pense y avait quelqu'un
qui s'était désisté du jeu de baston
c'est pas mal ce n'est pas moi le
l'animateur s'était et julie raynaud
juillet des nouveautés une amie donc
elle m'adapter pas ce que vaut
exactement voilà sinon rien à retirer au
moment de partir chacun met son boulot
et vous partez et on dit bon à la
prochaine la prochaine mais sans moi
parce que moi c'est ma dernière mission
et ils vous le dit mais pourquoi de ces
dernières n'est pas parce que j'ai
démissionné le figaro donc j'ai plus
rien à faire ici jiabao kéba une autre
fois ailleurs il vous repartez vous
arrêter pour ce qu'elle est toute ma vie
vous vous retournez vous dit j'y pense
tu vas faire quoi après juba où je ne
sais pas il ya chaque un casting jeudi
prochain si ça t'amuse n'a rien à faire
passe et je suis allé au casting
j'aurais tpiy sas pour moi j'étais pas
là il se trouve que heureusement chaque
semaine c'est dommage loquace et je vais
percer chacun d'eux une chronique
c'était samuel etienne qui faisait de
l'animateur d'invités de faisabilité à
ce jour là c'était un pilote qui n'était
pas diffusée et il y avait plein de bons
basten jeune fille j'étais persuadé pas
être pris et ma deuxième chance etc avec
yannick bolloré qui était acté votre ami
et associé et je le connais c'est parce
que comme je travaille au service télé
du figaro j'avais rencontré faire des
interviews puis je crois qu'il aimait
bien les médias il m'aimait bien aller
pour la diane team lundi un petit mot
sur mesure et à vous et je crois que
c'est ça qui a fait que babouche
autrement je pense que jamais vous
auriez embauché donc merci yannick
jamais seul le remercier parce que c'est
lui qui m'approche je sais quoi moi je
vous dis la vérité c'est que vous aviez
fait un papier sur moi sur hanouna plage
dans le figaro j'ai fait l'émission
encore dans les campings ouais et vous
avez été moi je me rappelle on m'avait
dit tu vas rencontrer jean michel maire
fait attention c'est un intello
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai discuté avec des patrons de
radio qui m'ont dit à l'époque jean
michel maire faisait peur à tout le
monde des médias
vraiment c'est pas vrai s'est dit tu vas
rencontrer jean michel maire fait
attention c'est un ponte du journalisme
c'est dans le c'est lui qui fait la
pluie le beau temps au figaro sur la
télé donc je te le dis il faut que tu
sois très bon et je les ai rencontrés
alors je n'essaie pas du tout jean
michel maire nous quand ils étaient ils
étaient hyper sérieux savent allumé un
slip et où je me suis alors mais il est
et je vous jure que c'est vrai et donc
j'ai fait des interviews avec lui et il
a été super sympa dans le papier c'est
vrai vous avez fait un très bien se
replier sur soi voilà et derrière c'est
vrai que l'on associé m'avait dit jean
michel maire est un excellent
journaliste je pense qu'il le faudrait
avec toro plus ça va vraiment élever le
niveau après l'émission
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
comment vous avez été recruté vous vous
m'avez appelé vous m'avez dit j'ai
besoin de gens célèbres maintenant
autour de la table la vérité non j'avais
été remerciés d'un commun accord avec
nrj12 par là avec eux mêmes et vous avez
les gars c'est dérisoire et j'ai été
dégagée d'nrj12 et vous m'avez appelé on
m'avait dit ça serait bien qu'on se
rencontre pour voir peut-être l'année
prochaine faire quelque chose ensemble
est ce que vous pouvez me joindre à
votre bureau à une heure précise qui
était 10 heures ouais je suis passé à
11h45
j'ai attendu une heure quarante-cinq ans
bah quand même on va et quand je suis
monté ben on s'est rencontré et je suis
vous m'avez dit toi tu es intelligent tu
seras tu seras le monsieur médias là on
va ta bille et bien cravate nam nam nam
nam tient très bien très bien
et monsieur surtout petite anecdote
cocasse vous m'aviez dit c'est quoi ton
tarifs
alors j'ai dit je veux tu en es tu m'as
dit c'est bon le tarif c'est bon et
c'est un contrat de un an
deux semaines après j'arrive chez h2o
c'est un contrat de trois moins que tu
arrives c'est à la moitié alors maxime
comment vous l'avez été recrutés on m'a
appelé pendant les vacances de noël 2016
a dit est ce que tu veux participer à
l'émission en tant qu'expert médias on a
envie de légitimer un peu le programme
sur la partie c'est vraiment planté
on sait on était à côté reste qu'on dit
quand on veut séduire ça on était sur
l'a13 ont appris la table et je me suis
dis franchement c'est une belle
opportunité c'est quitte ou double soit
je me plante totalement ce qui est
arrivé on le début janvier
j'arrivais le 5 janvier et les émissions
précédentes je les ai regardés avec la
plus grande et sunnites a assez dit et
je tremblais tous mes membres n'ont
jamais inquiet dit je m'installe à la
salle maquillage et anorak me fais mes
jeunes hommes qui êtes vous je suis à
l'expert média du jour
ah ouais je le sais bien on n'a pas de
beau gosse dont l'équipe a après le fait
et on va me fais une petite bise sur la
joue
et puis j'ai trouvé l'amour elle nous
racontera ça la vie et puis après de fil
en aiguille semaine après semaine du
vote d
[Applaudissements]
et oui la prétention du gade donc
banques que de beau gosse de l'émission
non non je n'ai rien dire ça mais année
d'enora l'époque côté coloris n'aura
elle s'attend à la mort il est très
gentil en fait elle dit ça tout le monde
de la nuit on lui pose la question
voilà la valse l'ami très à l'aise et
j'ai fait des émissions et la 11e j'ai
eu mon premier cachet de la crise et une
fois toujours bien
[Musique]